[Music]
for those partial to pageantry it's been
a year like no other and for the king a
Year of Firsts now his first birthday
parade not seen since 1986 a monarch on
Horseback heading to horse guards Celia
and Junior Royals following
so much has changed within the family
but trooping the color are constant in
the Royal calendar
[Music]
on horse guards parade the king inspects
his waiting troops the first king to do
so since 1950.
[Music]
it is a complex drill and a gift from
the soldiers to their colonel in Chief
this is Central London in full
ceremonial mode
and from the marching to the Flying
Alice the balcony moment with crowds
rushing to bag the best spot
Coronation Day Rain grounded most of
these aircraft a delayed display now
taking shape
of course the king's been to trooping
the color many times before but never
just for him this is his first official
birthday and a significant moment for
him to show the bond between Monarch and
Military
's a family favorite and a reminder the
faces here may change but their
Traditions with some little additions
stay the same Laura bundock Sky News at
Buckingham Palace